the senior commander of the palestinian
armed group al-aqsa brigades has been
killed and arrayed by israeli forces in
the occupied west bank the military says
it surrounded the home of ibrahim
nabulsi before an exchange of gunfire
two others were killed in the operation
more than 40 people were reported
injured
naval sea was widely known as the lion
of nablus israel blamed him for a series
of attacks on its forces he was a senior
figure in al-aqsa brigades a coalition
of palestinian-armed groups in the
occupied west bank nabulsi had been
targeted in two previous israeli
operations two palestinians were killed
in the last one in july
well john holman joins us now live from
nablus john you've just arrived at the
scene of the raid what more can you tell
us about what's happening there now
actually we're at the hospital right now
in nablus this is where the latest
numbers we have are more than 60 people
injured we're getting that from the red
crescent um and uh three people as you
mentioned that were killed in this uh
the uh so as well as ibrahim er ao
nabusi also two other people one of them
in an apartment with him and also a 16
year old so you can see how many people
that are out and around here is sort of
testament to how popular here
this leader of the al-aqsa martyrs
brigade was uh he's
he was young uh and people say here
quite charismatic he had a strong
presence on social media as well so you
can see a lot of young people here we
just had the family as well go past us
uh later on today uh reasonably soon
actually we'll probably have
also the funeral um because the body is
here uh as well now we've just been
spoken speaking to an eyewitness someone
was here while the raid took place and
basically confirming some of the details
that also the israeli military gave out
which was that they had an area in the
old town of nablus surrounded
and then they went after uh ibrahim
al-nabul
who barricaded himself
into a building
with gunmen who were
supporting him
that raid lasted or attacked by the
israeli forces lasted for a number of
hours people are saying here from 5am
till 9 00 am
in the morning they also fired a missile
a shoulder
fired missile at some point and there
was also gas is what people here were
telling us used to disperse people a
tear gas
type suspense
you can just hear people as well like
and sort of shouting slogans and things
like that just as we're transmitting
after that
um the leader of one of the leaders of
alexa martin's brigade uh
was killed uh
and this is important as well um because
this happened in area a nablus where we
are right now is area a so just to
explain to our audience this is an area
in which israeli forces under the oslo
agreement aren't actually meant to go
into and in this occasion they obviously
went in in force it's not completely
unusual for them to commit to go in and
raid
areas like nablus it is not that common
for them to go in with the number of
people with the number of soldiers that
they did so and it's also not that
common for them to do it during the
hours of daylight as opposed to in the
middle of the night
so
definitely there's a general strike here
also in nablus that we're hearing is
also expanding to ramallah as people uh
mourn
the death of this commander and just on
him he was obviously dubbed the lion of
nablus so just how significant is his
death
i think it's hugely significant to the
people here in nablus if we're talking
about the picture of israel and the
occupied territories as a whole
the al-aqsa martyrs brigade is the
military arm of
fatah which is the dominant organization
here and of course you've got the
palestinian authority but it is separate
from islamic jihad now for our audience
who's been watching us in the last few
days
the
problems and the escalation in gaza is
between the israeli state and islamic
jihad a more powerful group
so this is separate uh from that
conflict what is interesting about this
is that israel just after
this escalation with gaza they've only
just had a ceasefire broken by the
egyptians and uh they still sent forces
into here now we've been speaking to
analysts within israel that have been
sort of highlighting that and saying
that that's really a sign of israel uh
trying to fragment and divide the two to
say well that ceasefire is one thing
that doesn't mean that we're going to
stop acting
against other armed groups in the
occupied west bank and we're not going
to sort of stay our hand
from going after
them at the moment
john holman
thank you very much for that update